train un rêve de gastronomes maintenant
les plus grands chefs de france étaient
réunis à table pour rendre hommage à
fernand point
fernand point a été le premier à obtenir
trois étoiles au michelin c'était en
présentation du menu didier guyot philip
spivey embrassades et retrouvailles pour
le repas le plus étoilé de france ne
vaut cusa troisgros de ducasse à michel
bras ils sont tous venus festoyer au
restaurant la pyramide à vienne pour la
mémoire et d'histoire de la cuisine
française a pour nom fernand point un
monument de la gastronomie entre 1933 à
1955 le monde entier venaient lui rendre
visite
le monde entier parce que là ça fort la
gac en surpoids soit le monde entier par
ses vieux jours au spectacle spectacle
gaza mois la cuisse coupé rendez vous
patrick henri roux l'actuel chef de la
pyramide a mis les petits plats dans les
grands tous ces convives
c'est un rêve d'enfant le menu se doit
d'être prestigieux on va manger le foie
gras en brioche on va manger un gratin
de queues d'écrevisses à la fille du
château de gruyères va manger a sûrement
au chant ty une poularde autruches
fourchette à la main les 50 étoiles
michelin réunie autour de toutes ces
tables on le palais entraîné délicat et
pourtant même avec des clients
difficiles
la magie de la cuisine hop r b et bailly
devant le
découpage de la volaille ans à la
volaille en récit des grands classiques
et je dois dire ce forestier et on a
besoin d'être ensemble et ria pas que
les acteurs de la cuisine est aussi de
20 le service de sal les producteurs en
envoie quelques-uns aussi aujourd'hui
c'est finalement c'est une grande
famille
un air d'accordéon pour terminer ce
repas en famille sans oublier la photo
pour la postérité prochain repas et
toilette dans un domicile